the rest of Imran Khan has put Pakistan
on the brink here's what you need to
know
[Music]
Pakistan is the Muslim world's second
most popular state and the only Islamic
nuclear state it has a big military some
seriously contentious borders and it
plays a major role regionally and
globally a resolution to the Kashmir
conflict or lasting peace in Afghanistan
wouldn't really be possible without
Pakistan playing a major role
Pakistan is in a pretty dire economic
State it's facing inflation and it's
foreign reserves have plummeted as well
it's politically
extremely polarized with regular
protests taking place and there's been a
rise in Terror attacks too and you've
got these big institutions locked in a
power struggle while ordinary pakistanis
are really struggling
[Music]
a lot of people are also still
recovering from the devastating floods
of last year and we're seeing the
poorest communities hit at the very
sharp end of climate change
foreign
s here in Pakistan is crucial to Global
Security no one can afford for this
state to fail but these are very
precarious times